hello everyone welcome to simulation I'm
your host Don Sakia and boom we got a
great show coming up today we have dr.
Roman Young Polsky joining us today
Roman you're in Louisville right now
right yep awesome thank you so much for
coming on to the show
Roman is an incredible background really
focused on AI safety and security right
now but he got his PhD at the University
of Buffalo in computer science and
engineering and then he also studied
behavior of biometrics which I'm in in
the unification of those and using
sensors which I find to be very
interesting I'm excited to ask you a
little bit about that that whole
industry of biotech is exploding and now
you founded the cybersecurity lab you've
been at the University of Louisville
about 10 years now
that's a blip lots of lots of teaching
of kids become future leaders yeah too
many too many but you've gotten so many
really incredible awards as well for
professing which is awesome
all right let's um you you you authored
artificial superintelligence now ai
safety Security's coming up so let's
let's dive into this tell me a little
bit about about your background like
where you're from how did you even get
into computer science engineering
[Music]
everything about it so that was a given
were you born in the u.s. Latvia cool
this is nice think I've devised for
risky Ghana awesome I'm Armenian it's
great you know speak a little bit and
okay cool so then you moved here to the
US when you were young I was fifteen
there's a 10 15 cool and then you ended
up figuring out how did you and then you
said that you were
always like playing around with
computers did you do did you know that
like when did AI come into the equation
that's always an interesting question
ask people well again with games it's
always important to make an interesting
opponent in a game right a cool boss or
fighting sparring partner so yeah I was
kind of always part of it I was also
very interested in online poker where
again my opponents are very important so
it was nothing anything else yeah
there's a whenever I pull it whenever I
play games cuz I was a prolific gamer in
the past you know there's always you
wonder how well the computer will learn
about your skill level and then change
its level of skill according to how
strong you are playing yourself and
there's all different types of and now
we have alpha zero roaming around
destroying alpha go players DOTA dota2
such a difficult game to figure out how
to play and and he's so dynamic okay
we'll get there how about this behavior
of biometrics this seems like a space
that is there just trying to figure out
how do you measure someone's proteomics
their genome all these omics and then
how do you provide relatable insights to
somebody ahead of time and like what
were the sensors you're using how are
you unifying biometrics anything can be
profile where you work where you talk so
there is lots of data to be used and
multi-dimensional behavioral biometrics
a great way to increase accuracy for
what it's typically considered a weaker
form of
and so though one that you mentioned was
like building these profiles about
people that seems to also be very
relating to what happened with Cambridge
analytical as well absolutely
Veda I was used to just watching people
play poker and try to figure out their
betting patterns but Facebook obviously
gives you so much more what you like and
like who you follow your friends that
you can predict ahead of time divorce
marriage really unlimited source of data
poker end of things it was really
building up a profile of when somebody's
gonna this is what a lot of poker
players do I remember doing this myself
when I was playing Hold'em you'd walk in
and you just try and identify you'd
watch the game and you try and find the
tables that had the players that were
fairly weak they call them fish and
uhyou try and do that to find the best
table because again you're not playing
against the house you're playing against
other players
so then with things like like you just
described with the camber janaloka when
you take that much data from people's
likes dislikes who they talk to who they
follow you can figure out yeah things
like when they're gonna get even
divorced that's crazy it seems like now
let's maybe walk us into the founding of
the cybersecurity lab how how long into
the professing did did that come into
play so my research can move from
profiling people to very naturally
profile in poker bots it seems like the
same technologies could be used to
figure out which bar is playing in to
prevent bots but CAPTCHA algorithms and
so that was my PhD work and immediately
after coming to Louisville I started 11
continued working on
started the lab the cybersecurity lab
what what were the main like principles
that you started that with and what were
you continuing to work on well I always
wanted to look at security and I really
feel there is no need to so this applies
to everything security of cyberspace
security virtual worlds behavioral
profiling safety and security of
intelligent systems I mean I stick my
notes of many facts it's really anything
where we can make a contribution but the
last five years it's mostly safety of
intelligent systems yeah so okay what's
the difference between an assistant and
an associate professor ah it's a
wonderful question but is really almost
no difference there's like a tenured
professor professor and senior professor
for fool
so assistant professor doesn't assist
anyone and associate professors not
associated with anything though I think
full professors are proud full of
something really just stages in your
career the nice bonus of being
associated professor is usually tenure
so you can actually do crazy things like
super intelligence research
okay so then after you assistant
professor for six years the almost four
years now of associate professor it
gives you more room for research being
an associate professor all right so you
have really no limits in terms of what
you can look at you have complete
academic freedom with Kenya
wow that is awesome complete academic
freedom yeah to go and that did that
that gave you enough time to write the
first book artificial superintelligence
walk us down kind of the the thesis of
that book so it was around the same time
as Boston superintelligence but I think
it was more from the computer science
point of view less from philosophy point
of view would like to be a little more
formal bring a little more from a
cybersecurity angle really maybe for
like advanced person interested in the
eye safety if Boston is really
accessible to everyone this probably is
like second level and so walk us a
little bit through what boström was
saying and kind of what you're saying
everyone what the concerns some possible
ways to it and I kind of take it to a
deeper level from computer science point
of view how can we prove some of those
things what are the actual problems how
can we learn from cyber security and
cryptography in other domains so more
the connection to computer science area
so Bostrom's thesis was that we have all
these issues that we face a good amount
of issue with with generating an
artificial superintelligence and your
thesis is that we if we leverage
cybersecurity cryptography if we
leverage some of these tools we can
better address what that future with
it's gonna look like well it's useful to
help us tools to understand what the
problem is philosophers identifying big
problems the future but even today we're
starting to have problems with existing
AI systems and you need a computer
scientist to address them sort of
applied philosopher ideas now oh that's
fascinating so now we need to have an
applied philosopher working
with the AI developers exactly so we
have people who are very good at kind of
programming engineering but may not have
moral philosophy ethics and so it's good
to have someone who can reach those
different disciplines and connect them
and more and more we see big players in
the industry recognizes need I love the
idea of not even being able to develop
an AI without a philosopher that's funny
the to package them together it's almost
crucial when did you kind of come up
with that realization well it's over
multiple years that kind of slowly grew
in that so as I said I started doing
security against poker bots then I
realized we can kind of develop better
tools and parts also advancing so this
race condition between you know
improving artificial intelligence that
improved safety mechanisms well where is
it going what's the final destination
for that and that's where I kind of
started looking at work what was
singularity Institute at the time and
trying to connect the dots between
state-of-the-art and cybersecurity and
concerns about artificial
superintelligence so that kind of leads
us into this you read that when when is
this AI safety and security this next
book of yours when are you is it gonna
happen by the end of this year you think
I'm hoping for the summer but it's
optimistic I'm still going through the
process of editing in publisher but it's
expedited so I really hope for the
summer so now walk us down maybe some of
the the current issues that we're facing
in the safety and security of AI and
then how we're applying cyber security
cryptography philosophy to address those
security and safety concerns so the
discipline is much bigger now there is a
lot of people working on different
projects and there is a lot of interest
there is a lot of work on regulation
and governments Ovi which was not the
case before there is also so much work
on kind of current issues with
algorithms are they explainable they
fair to all types of people whatever
it's minority swimming is there any bias
and the algorithms cooked in so those
that were kind of new sub domains which
are becoming more prominent lately so
how do how do we who is this person that
would then work with the AI so would it
be the philosopher the ply foster that
would then speak with the programmers
and say hey how easily explainable is
this algorithm have we I'd looked for
any biases safety security is that
usually the conversation that would
happen the bias issue could be addressed
probably by social scientists just as
well but a lot of companies which are
sort of on a verge of making something
very advanced maybe they have enough
hardware resources available coming up
with a new learning transfer approach
they are more concerned about the long
term issues what happens then we get the
human level and beyond super
intelligence so they are the ones who
look at kind of philosophical
implications in this work as well as
obviously safety expertise and making
sure that this process is controlled
because it is you would you agree that
this is the most likely the largest
existential threat that society faces I
think so it's really hard to come up
with something more important and also
something which is if done correctly
will help us as much to address all
other existential risks I really love
the the positive view on it that there's
so much good that can come from it but
at the same time there's so much that
needs to be discussed now I guess let's
ask you this Roman do you think that we
should have more global
Asians about what this looks like how do
you think the US should work with China
across the world as we develop this out
what's the what are the best practice is
what's part of ongoing research how do
we collaborate in this how do we share
information on safety so far there is
not much state-level
there certain conference is trying to
kinda introduce the problem so I
recently spoke at a moral government
summit which had representatives from
probably well over a hundred countries
to be some movement in the right
direction but it's not enough at this
point national events definitely
happened there is a I always see
roundtables and workshops happening in
US and abroad but it's not very well
unified there is also some work at you
UN but again the limits so we we take
the development of the United States and
AI and China and AI we're not really
open sourcing a lot of this information
yet do you as we move on it seems to be
that we're gonna move towards a more of
an open sourcing datasets
decentralization that should help a lot
with finding these unique insights into
datasets yes but at the same time making
everything open-source make it
accessible malevolent players bad actors
whatever it's basic people terrorist
hackers they would have access to the
latest in the United how much it's a
safe alternative as well Wow
okay so that's a really difficult
balance to strike then we got to be open
source enough to where people around the
world that are trying to do for good are
using it but not enabling terrorists and
malevolent players to leverage it what
it what how would that how would that
look like that balance that's open any
search question there are multiple
papers now on open a yeah I'm just
open the truth is there a hazardous
information in it should we only share
it with other experts or should really
be public and of course there is all
this insider information we don't know
what is being developed by governments
you know NSA and whatever Chinese
equivalent Russian equivalent is we just
don't know what the state of the art is
I'm there I'm maybe a good one would be
the background check before you get
access to the data set are they I
Snowden Snowden well in tell us a little
bit more about why you say that well
humans are not safe no matter what we
culture religion Aemon they always bad
indicator how likely we are to succeed
with super intelligent systems as
serious of a field as you're studying
you have probably one of the funniest
social profiles that I've ever the
stumbled upon you got the funniest memes
that you're posting the funniest short
videos they're hilarious a lot of them
are like you know making fun of things
like oops the the a I ordered a thousand
pizzas or wilfer your house or things
like this that are just that are just
very funny
so as serious as you are there as funny
as you are there it also interesting
that you're also so serious I think why
do you strike that that that hilarity I
think that's that's really incredibly
important to be funny as you talk about
this if you study the way intelligent
systems fail there was a very similar to
what makes a joke funny right there is
mismatch of types there is
miscalculation of dimensions so really
joke suggests an easy to memorize
failures of humans and intelligent
systems so some of my researches in
alive
in AI fails and think that's kind of
very easy to remember a continuation
those problems
there's no prima 2d killer situation yet
kind of the same it's definitely at some
point in his career Boston immediate
perhaps that's there's a whole field
being born of humor for AI fails well if
you can predict why certain situations
very humorous you can also predict how
that system can fail in it so it's it's
good to have a good sense of humor it
also helps you sleep at night knowing
what might happen yeah what now what do
you think about currently we are at
somewhere around eight people have as
much wealth as the bottom four billion
or so what do you think about this gap
of wealth inequality and what's gonna
happen with AI and robotics and biotech
and space colonization all these things
proliferating especially with easier
access to people that are more wealthy
what are your thoughts about that
so there's a certain danger to so much
difference in power right single person
can I pass laws and really do anything
they want especially in certain
countries maybe more legally established
boundaries but it's also an opportunity
wanted to see evalee received she would
stand work you have to like with
anything else look at both positives and
negatives yeah there is that really
addictive it's an addiction to power
once it kind of keeps you keep
leveraging money to bypass rules like
you said that is a nuts nuts feeling and
then on the other side of things there's
all this good that we can do now
do you do you do you worry about a
class-based speciation or like a
bifurcation of society and two different
you know either the super rich or the
poor I'm much less concerned about
economic issues they're important but
they are solvable we know how to solve
them it's more question of do we want to
solve them where is I'm more concerned
about problems we don't know salt but I
know how to make safe and controllable
superintelligence and obviously economic
unemployment logical and employment are
important we need to address AB some
conditional basic income conditional
basic assets at the end of the day
enough income for termination
yeah that's that's exactly right
the overall extermination of society is
much more worrisome than the speciation
in wealth so they're very close the
second one's very close to that first
one as well but let's okay let's let's
unpack maybe some of the some of the
current systems that exist and are they
are they running on closed loops like
open AI is trying to you know help share
AI safety and security with the world
meanwhile you never know you know China
was doing genetic engineering
experiments we don't know kind of what
if there if anyone right now is letting
a I just run openly on the web now yeah
what maybe tell us a little bit about
that well there are certain things we
don't know there could be powerful
players national state level players who
do work in this area but we're not aware
of what they have accomplished it's also
possible that the problem is actually
easier than what we think maybe it's
possible to be CDI and a laptop in your
garage I'm just gonna let it grow and
not require too much computational power
it's unlikely but it's still possible so
we're not sure at this point it looks
like most likely it's the big players
Google's of the world who have necessary
hardware to make it happen first but
it's not a guarantee as well and would
would you say that this overall best
practice is to keep it on closed
networks first well obviously just
leasing it out there and seeing what
happens it's never a good idea you want
to have a test environment you wanna
make sure whatever it is you expect it
to do at least that is done and again
I'm talking about just advanced systems
not human level or anything beyond that
yeah so okay so maybe what would you say
are these first principles of advanced
systems and AI so you start with a
closed system you test with a small
group then you maybe open it up a little
bit larger keep testing and making sure
it's not malevolent in any way all right
but the problem is how do you test it
for anyway right
that's limited by our imagination if we
can come up with a loophole doesn't mean
there isn't one and it's important to
look at the state-of-the-art in the eye
safety right now so as far as I know as
of today no one has a working safety
mechanism capable of scaling to any
level intelligence no one even has a
prototype for such a system which is
likely to be built in the next year or
two or three so if you are working on
something very advanced and you feel
like okay we're about to succeed I just
need to you know let it run over a few
months and this very powerful Wow
probably not a good idea just running it
and seeing what happens
would so that that's fascinating that
there's nobody's really cracking the AI
safety code quite yet figuring out how
to keep all of the that AI that is built
to be completely safe as it goes and
does its tasks so you think that we're
gonna leverage maybe like a
moment-to-moment cryptography on this
system that might be a way to keep it
safe
well repugnantly certainly is necessary
to protect it from again malevolent
humans making changes to it stealing the
code but it seems like mostly our safety
research is about discovering new
problems and new things we didn't
consider before very little of it is
actually solving something permanently
in going okay this is no longer an issue
it seems like it's a tracker the more we
zoom in the more we realize there is
even more problems to be handled so I
think we're very far from having of
working safety mechanism which is 100%
safe and secure and can scale as the
system learns and becomes even more
capable I feel like I'm taking the AI
safety 101 course right now I love it
is is maybe we'll do course 102 soon as
well what do you what would you say some
of the like AI safety and security 101
for your students what have been some of
those like top tips that you've told
them and then maybe some of the top
realizations that they've had so it's
surprising but most developers
researchers have never honestly
considered in any depth what happens if
they succeed so you can go to a top like
I conference that is 10,000 researchers
there but maybe 2030 will attend the
workshop on AI safety and the rest have
no idea what's going on there it's
starting to change a little but not
enough most people it's about making the
system as capable as soon as possible
and safety and security is something you
add later and then we made this mistake
many times before that's how we
developed internet and now it's
completely insecure we repeating this
mistake with Internet
pour into alternative things so we're
just adding things to the infrastructure
but they are absolutely unsecured and we
might repeat this mistake with AI again
we're just trying to make intelligent
systems get there first whatever is
releasing a fleet of self-driving cars
to collect more data and beat the
competition or something as trivial as a
chat bot with Elise and see how it
happened you know performs with real
users will have a pattern of this
performance over safety reference and
that's what markets usually prefer
that's fascinating we do have a pattern
of performance over safety that's a
really good way to put it and and this
is the most and I think that applied to
you know biotechnology and bio warfare
as well as you know we need a prioritize
safety as biohackers go about the world
so that's really interesting so there's
conferences going on where there's just
a few people attending the safety and
security conversations and it's it's
almost the so many of the conversations
today go from zero to 100 meaning at
zero as AI is nothing and 100 as AI is
AGI and it's killing everybody
and but there's all this one two five
seven that are how do you bring AI and
safety and security as we build AI into
the world and right now there isn't
enough of those little smaller
conversations about what engineers are
in designers are building AI for and how
to keep it safe and secure so in a way
it's kind of sad but the way the eyes
fail is kind of helping us to bring
attention to the problem right the
Microsoft shed but they starts spewing
racist garbage everyone writes about it
so now people are worrying about chat
box being safe then a self-driving car
kills someone it's a tragedy for the
person but the field there is a lot more
interest and funding now for preventing
it from happening and I think we'll see
more and more of accidents failures and
we will become more and more
impact and I think that's gonna drive
them also very fascinating so the more
that we focus on performance and the
more that it fails along the way the
more like you said Microsoft's Chapas
racist garbage the car that ends up
failing and killing somebody the more
media and press we get about these AI
failures the more that will realize that
safety and security let's all focus on
that so so interesting is there a let's
ask you a couple other of our simulation
questions maybe we asked you about what
do you think is the most beautiful thing
in the world
intelligence it's a good answer I like
that and maybe maybe tell us why or
unpack that a little bit it seems like
everything else can be derived from it
like if you like art you can generate
beautiful art if you like jokes you can
certainly crack a good joke if you're
smart enough everything else can be
reduced to having a very very capable
intelligent system
would you say that the animal possesses
a little bit less intelligence than the
human does it has less general
intelligence it might be much more
intelligent in some narrow domain that
animal here is about yeah okay
how about what is something that you
believe to be true that almost nobody
else believes to be true
I made a post for April first a joke
that something like eighty four point
six percent of all conspiracy he is a
false but I never discussed the other
percentage
maybe maybe you do discuss what what are
those 15 percent of these conspiracies
that are very fascinating that could be
true so I'll just kind of maybe
abstractly talk about it we have a very
strong skeptic movement right and
usually the target nonsense they go
after horoscopes and flatterer up
society and all those things which are
obviously worthless there is no need to
invest resources in even debating those
issues whereas they rarely try to
question what the mainstream believes in
science and there is a lot more benefit
to doing that if you look at history of
science every theory which was
previously held as the right answer has
later been over overturned by something
that came after sometimes it's a
complimentary change sometimes it's a
complete revolution but this will
continue and everything we believe today
will be replaced by a future that's
really wanna pay attention yeah the the
skeptic movement is is very fascinating
I've even you know June Yoon's been on
our show a couple of times and he has
been kind of this big proponent of
saying you know be the black sheep
really think when 99 sheep are moving in
one direction what is you black sheep
can move in the direction of what could
that one thing be that nobody else is
looking at and you know Peter Thiel
talks about it as well when he talks
about making monopolies and really
thinking about that and business and
culture as well I do find that to be
crucial crucially important especially
with today's addiction to echo chamber
style social media to really be always
keep an eye of skepticism more and more
people are starting to say that keep a
skeptical eye as you're looking at data
as you're looking at social media so
okay how about do you think we're alone
in the cosmos
very unlike would you hypothesize that
the life is like this also kind of this
flush vehicle life carbon-based DNA life
or what do you think it's like it seems
after a while if the progress we have
here is typical of carbon life becomes
something else
Digital informational so I suspect more
advanced civilizations artificially
designed
yeah yeah information digital life is
where Dino do what do you do you think
that the consciousness the consciousness
ends up moving away from the flesh
vehicle to being able to live away from
being in the trapped in the body I have
a recent paper about exactly that
question so what is consciousness can we
detect it and my belief is that it's a
side effect of computation of thinking
of processing information
so whatever substrate is engaged in this
process will have some type of
consciousness it may not be it's never
the same as another being but there is
definitely some quality of something
it's like to be that information
processing machine that's fascinating so
so this information processing machine
can't be the same as another one because
it would it would literally need to see
everything the exact same way and
process it in the exact same way in
order for it to be the exact same okay
so now we have these like let's call
them snowflakes of consciousness that
are on the seven and a half billion
let's say of us that are here on this
earth what would be the steps that you
think to take the consciousness from
being localized in this nervous system
to being able to live more digitally as
a system of perception and thinking so
mine uploading be possible may be a very
complex process but we can certainly
envision eating a complete simulation of
a human being human mind environment of
that person their body so maybe we can
translate it into a machine and then
enhance it
give it more advanced consciousness
ability to have multiple streams of
consciousness at the same time and
acting it whatever Minds things like
that
do you now do you think that the up of
the upload this process of uploading is
this so-called this is kind of already
happening with my Facebook and LinkedIn
and Instagram and Twitter and all this
stuff right so we're already kind of
uploading ourselves in a way but all
these other like little interpersonal
quarks quirks and personality traits are
a little bit more difficult to then
become part of your this digital profile
but do you think that kind of our
current appendage connection to laptops
and computers and social media is
already creating that our mind on the
Internet of digital consciousness you
may be transferring some memory but to
experience fully what it's like to be
you all the sensors your vision your
hearing everything else about you would
have to be replicated as well so you may
be doing some useful work but it's not
gonna get you all the way to a complete
copy room and how would a digital
consciousness be able to see and hear
and taste and touch feel so you were
doing a physical or a simulated set of
sensors some sort of body but again not
necessarily biological one
so they would be sensors than in the
digital world that we would we would
figure out how to make the a sensor on
that on that for that consciousness I'm
sure I can go ahead they are not limited
to what we have it doesn't have to be
the same census you can have a sense for
what the stock market is doing you can
have a sense for Wikipedia you can have
all sorts of information input devices
which we are not enjoying right now you
can look at what animals do some have
infrared vision night-vision magnetic
sensors there is really no limit to what
you can plug into them Wow
so yeah mint digital consciousness with
abundance and unlimited capacity of
perception Wow okay so um and to now do
with this with this space do you do you
think that there are advanced
civilizations roaming the cosmos I think
so I I do also think that that is very
likely and I think that it's um it's
very fascinating to think about how they
got there because then we can then
potentially try and model similar
behaviors so that we can also
potentially get there I mean we're in
the process doing what they did to get
where they are we're going to expose
them soon yeah that's my favorite who am
I mistaken kill ourselves before we get
to advanced levels they suspect a lot of
civilizations fail to pass this great
filter of developing great intelligence
and not falling a victim - yes there's
the the filters are crazy the nuclear
war the bio warfare the AI the asteroids
there's so many of these filters that
can kill a civilization along the way
and it's it's it's amazing to be able to
develop the tools to prevent the safety
and security of too
prevent AI biowarfare to prevent nukes
to prevent asteroids from killing us
even that is that is an intelligent
civilization one that lives on multiple
rocks multiple star systems knows how to
travel between them
eradicate saz much suffering as possible
I love all of that they do do you think
that this is base reality or that we're
in a simulation it's more likely to be
simulation yes
read a bit more about why you think that
statistically it would be very unlikely
that we just happen to be so specialist
to be the number one out of all possible
simulations within simulations so is it
does this kind of take us to the
previous question about how vast the
cosmos are what the advanced
civilization what technology would the
advanced civilization need in order to
make a simulation would it be like
quantum mechanics and solar and nuclear
fusion that kind of stuff
it depends what you're simulating you
can have a very basic simulation like a
video game 8-bit simulation and the
question is do you have conscious beings
experiencing it from the hard part again
it's intelligence and consciousness
graphics around it could be anything you
decided to be the god in that game I
love I love that that notion of being
the the the controller of the simulation
and and being able to tweak all these
different variables like gravity the
proximity of the star to the planet how
many how quick evolution occurred to
produce this consciousness that has
processing power of human level or
greater okay and how about a another
question for you
let's ask do you think that there is an
inherent meaning or purpose to life
there is not destination the purpose of
life is not a place you get to it's a
direction right so it's the journey if
you devote your life to making the world
a better place and and make sure that
all the side effects are also included
so to do that you have to exist you have
to live forever to continue doing that
you have to understand the world you
have to experience the world maybe
trying to collect all the possible
qualia at least the positive ones
what is
to do this what it's like you do that
that that could be a purpose right it's
not what people usually expect to hear
but if you try and adopt it it actually
creates for a very interesting life I
like that the idea that the purpose or
them the meaning is the journey together
and trying to make the world better
along the way okay do you have other
thoughts that you might want to share on
the program no not yet I discovered your
show couple days ago and I'm still in
the process of finding time to watch
some of the episodes so I'm curious what
you guys talk about
got a little bit of everything you got a
little bit of that you know clean meat
biotech digital data and DNA all that
stuff got a little bit of the AI and
robotics our future with that got a
little bit of neuroscience and brain tag
that we got some blockchain and
cryptocurrency and decentralization some
of the geopolitics geo-economics
conversations consciousness spirituality
meditation the the notion of being
multidisciplinary is something that we
take in really right in the center of
our hearts and and and helping other
people understand that having a little
bit of knowledge about a lot of
different things is is is helpful in
understanding the way that the world
works and how you can make it better
so that's experience so many things and
I'm very glad we discovered each other
room and very very glad I think a lot of
the things that you said today on the
program were very fascinating and
important for people to hear will
definitely clip out some of the some of
these like the ten second thirty second
really wise things and just throw them
online try and make them viral that's
something we're working on with our ok
with our with our computing and with our
computers and our premiere and our team
so all right let's let's close out dr.
Romania Polsky thank you so much for
joining us it's been such a pleasure
thank you thank you and hopefully we can
do some AI safety and security lesson
102 for you guys soon class 102 you can
follow Roman we'll put all his links in
the bio would highly recommend following
him very very funny hopefully we can
stumble upon more of those AI failures
and have them teach us more about the
importance of the security and safety
without hurting too many people along
the way thanks for tuning in if you guys
had a good time like comment subscribe
you can find us share the content with
other people online as well these are
really important conversations to have
about AI safety and security
and do check us out on patreon it helps
us support our studio helps us support
our equipment our team making a safe
space for other people so please check
us out there patreon.com for slash
simulation Sirius also in the bio thank
you very much for tuning in and we'll
see you guys soon with Robert Griffith
later today thank you very much